DIFFERENT A LITTLE BIT LATER ON
TODAY IN GEORGIA, SANDRA.
>> Sandra: PETER DOOCY AT THE
WHITE HOUSE FOR US, JOHN.
>> John: BILL de BLASIO
SENDING A TARGET AS YOU
MENTIONED AT THE TOP OF THE SHOW
TO GET THE BIG APPLE UP AND
RUNNING AT FULL CAPACITY.
LISTEN HERE.
>> IT IS TIME TO SET A GOAL FOR
A FULL REOPENING OF
NEW YORK CITY.
THAT GOAL IS JULY 1ST.
WE ARE READY TO BRING
NEW YORK CITY BACK FOLEY ON JULY
>> John: LET’S BRING IN
DR. MARTY MAKARY, AND FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR.
HE DID ISSUE THE CABBIE OUGHT
THERE LET’S SET A GOAL.
I’M SURE HE WOULD LIKE TO GET IT
OPEN JULY 1ST BUT IF
NEW YORK CITY CAN DO IT IN
NEW YORK CITY BEING A BLUE CITY
IN NEW YORK CITY LACKING BEHIND
THE RED STATES AND RED CITIES,
MIGHT THAT DR. McCARRICK GET
BACK UP?
>> I HOPE SO BUT NEW YORK HAS
BEEN LAGGING BEHIND AND THE REST
OF THE COUNTRY HAS A LOT OF
POPULATION-BASED IMMUNITY BUT
FIVE STATES LACKING IN OUTBREAKS
AMONG YOUNG PEOPLE AND NEW YORK
IS ONE OF THOSE.
CASES ARE DOWN 60% OVER THE LAST
FOUR WEEKS IN NEW YORK.
PEOPLE HAVE THE RIGHT TO ASK,
NOW THAT ROUGHLY 75% OF ADULTS
HAVE IMMUNITY, 54% VACCINATED
AND HALF NATURAL IMMUNITY ARE WE
IN A STATE OF EMERGENCY WITH LOW
LEVEL OF CASES?
THEN DON’T MAKE THE OF CASES
BELOW THAT MILD FLU SEASON.
THE DAILY CASES AND NEW
HOSPITALIZATIONS SO WE HAVE
DISTORTED PERCEPTION OF RISK.
THE CDC ISSUED GUIDANCE ON
REOPENING AND NOT JUST CLOSURES.
>> John: MAYOR de BLASIO
GIVING PEOPLE A REASON AND
SCHOOLS FULLY OPEN AND NOT TOO
LONG FROM NOW, HERE IS WHAT HE
SAID ON THAT, LISTEN.
>> LET ME TELL YOU SOMETHING OR
SEPTEMBER, FULL STRENGTH, NO
QUESTION IN MY MIND.
EVERY SINGLE CHILD CAN COME BACK
TO THE CLASSROOM AND DO SO
SAFELY.
THAT IS REALLY WHAT WE NEED.
WE NEED EVERYONE BACK IN SCHOOL.
>> John: ANOTHER GOAL OF
THAYER’S SEPTEMBER NEW YORK CITY
SCHOOLS MAKE IT BACK TO FULL IN
PERSON LEARNING.
I GUESS THE QUESTION IS DR.
MAKARY, WHY NOT NOW AND WAIT
UNTIL SEPTEMBER?
>> IT SHOULD BE NOW.
ACTUALLY IT SHOULD HAVE BEEN A
LONG TIME AGO.
BUT I THINK WHAT YOU ARE SEEING
IS POLICYMAKERS BY NATURE WITH
POLICY SAID THINGS THAT ARE
BASICALLY INSTITUTED IN
INDEFINITELY.
THEY MAKE LONG-TERM PLANS, BUT
THE SITUATION WITH COVID IS
FLUID.
YOU LOOK AT THE NUMBERS FOR THE
UNITED STATES AND EVEN NEW YORK,
I MEAN, GOSH, PLUMMETING IN
DAILY CASES, THE THREAT IS LOW
AND I WISH PEOPLE WOULD NOT JUST
TALK ABOUT THE SO-CALLED SAFETY
OF KIDS BEING OUT OF SCHOOL BUT
THE HARM, RIGHT?
LET ME KNOW IF YOU HAVE THE CDC
DIRECTOR OR DR. BOW CHIEF TALK
ABOUT SUICIDE OR PROFOUND
ISOLATION.
THOSE ARE ALTERNATIVES OF
CLOSURE.
SPEAK TO YOU MENTIONED GUIDANCE
JUST A SECOND AGO, DR. MAKARY
THE WATER COOLER TALK OF THE DAY
AND THAT IS WHY ALL OF THOSE
PEOPLE IN THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES LAST NIGHT FOR
THE PRESIDENT’S SPEECH WEARING
MASKS WHEN MOST IF NOT ALL OF
THEM ARE VACCINATED?
THE CDC GUY TO LET GO MY
GUIDANCE FROM ITS WEBSITE SAYS
GATHER INDOORS WITH FULLY
VACCINATED PEOPLE WITHOUT
WEARING A MASK OR STAYING 6 FEET
APART.
THEY WERE ALL WEARING MASKS,
SOME OF THEM WEARING TWO AND A
LONG WAY APART FROM EACH OTHER.
WHAT WAS THAT ABOUT?
>> WE HAVE COMPLETELY DISTORTED
RISK RIGHT NOW AND SENDING THE
WRONG MESSAGE.
WE NEED TO SEND A MESSAGE YOU
CAN BE LIBERATED AFTER A VACCINE
AND WAIT FOR THE IMMUNITY TO
THICKEN.
A REALLY GOOD ARTICLE IN
"THE WASHINGTON POST" BY DOMINIC
BASICALLY SAYING IT IS SENDING
THE WRONG MESSAGE.
THIS IS CONTRADICTING THE
MESSAGE WE ARE TRYING TO SEND.
>> John: DR. DR. MAKARY,
"THE WASHINGTON POST" WITH
DISTANCING, BIDEN SENDS THE WRON
MESSAGE ABOUT THE POWER OF THE
VACCINES.
THERE STILL A LITTLE BIT OF
HESITANCY BUT THAT FUEL TO EVEN
PUT THERE LAST NIGHT.
>> IT DID AND IF WE WANT TO BE
SERIOUS, LET’S STOP TALKING
ABOUT VACCINE MANDATES AND LET’S
RESPECT THOSE WHO CHOOSE NOT TO
GET THE VACCINE.
SOME HAVE A GOOD REASON.
PRIOR COVID INFECTION AND THEY
HAVE NATURAL IMMUNITY.
AND LET’S GIVE REWARDS AND
PRIVILEGES TO THOSE VACCINATED
AND CREATE MORE WALK-IN CLINICS
TO ELIMINATE BARRIERS.
LET’S STOP SHAMING PEOPLE THAT
CHOOSE NOT TO GET IT.
THAT IS A GOOD STRATEGY.
I THINK WE SHOULD STOP TALKING
ABOUT BOOSTERS.
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE WE WILL